hi everyone this is bruno azuza and i'm
here with sean and he is the brain
behind the anomaly detection design
pattern that we are launching this week
if you saw our earlier videos these
design patterns
are designed to help you get started and
develop
a solution to a business problem you
have so sean thank you so much for
taking the time
with us today tell us first of all what
is anomaly detection and why does it
matter
oh thanks for having me bruno appreciate
it you know first i need to let you know
that i've had three cups of coffee today
in the hope that i can show up here with
at least half as much energy as you do
but i don't think it's going to correct
i need to figure out what you have for
breakfast and have that for breakfast
lunch and dinner but anyway with that
let's talk about anomaly detection right
let me let me ask you this question uh
let's assume this was a regular working
day and you had to drive into work right
you probably saw hundreds and hundreds
of cars in the road
what are you one or two cars that you're
going to remember
yeah that's true i mean the my commute
was actually pretty easy this morning
but you're right that if
i drive to work i don't know i probably
remember a couple of cars
maybe maybe i saw three red cars but
apart from yeah maybe maybe one with the
flashy paint or maybe one that was
outside
right be it small on the smaller side or
a large cup right
now let me give you another scenario
right i've got an 18 month toddler at
home
she's a bundle of energy always running
around doing things asking for things
and and she's around us right so she
fades into the background
and then we go on with our life but the
minute that she's out of sight and we
don't hear anything from her that's when
we know she's up to something right
she's probably getting ready to test out
whether electrocution is fake news
i'm not like she's probably grabbing
something trying to insert the power
socket
now what is common between these two
scenarios it is the fact that right
you've got a constant stream of data
coming at you
but the data that is outlier or that is
unlike the others
is the one that is most interesting
right it gives you valuable perspective
tells you something new and in my case
potentially helps me avoid
data now that's basically what anomaly
detection is
right now beyond those you know simple
straightforward examples
you know it has a lot of applications
for our customers right let me give you
a few examples
let's say you're an e-commerce provider
right you know monitoring your
transaction data
monitoring your card data monitoring
your order information inventory
information real-time means
you're going to be able to detect fraud
much better and prevent fraudulent
activities before it's too late
here's another example let's say you're
a manufacturing customer right you've
got hundreds and hundreds of equipments
in your
factory flow right now being able to
analyze
um sensor data that is coming from those
equipments in real time
and being able to detect anomalous
patterns means you're able to schedule
proactive maintenance for maybe
equipment that is going to you know that
meets the
maintenance or you know you can pull out
equipment from your factory floor before
it is too late right otherwise you're
going to be able to uh you're going to
be dealing with expensive repairs
or even in some cases you allowed to
shut down your entire factory flow
right they are leading to significant
costs you know we talked about
e-commerce here talking about
manufacturing but of course
anomaly detection is appropriate in
financial services
in telecommunications so many of the
folks listening to us will be able to
apply that for
their business really regardless what
industry so you wrote a great detailed
blog on
the techniques being used and how people
can take advantage of it
take us through some of them we
published uh three different patterns as
of today
right so the the first one you know we
worked with the telecommunications
customer
um you know to build a network log-based
anomaly detection or intrusion detection
system
so this customer had a rule-based system
in place right so rule-based systems are
when you know you know of a specific you
know pattern or a signature for an
intrusion
and then you codify that in your system
right that works great
but the significant drawback of that is
it can only detect known packets
right now we all know the dynamic world
that we live in right
now there are new forms of inner network
attacks every day right it's a
constantly evolving landscape
and so we work with the customer to
implement ai technique called k-means
clustering it's basically an
unsupervised learning technique
uh to implement in a network detection
um a system uh based on their net
net flow logs let me give you another
example right so we work with a customer
uh who's basically a sas
platform uh you know their additional
trust and safety platform
basically provide anomaly detection as a
service for their customers
who are mostly your financial services
and e-commerce and
digital commerce lenders right so we um
you know that that customer was able to
leverage some of the patterns that we
published to very quickly get up and
running
roll out a production system and in fact
they were able to basically go to market
and scale and meet the needs of some of
the very large customers right and
their customers are some of the biggest
names that you would uh think of when i
when you think about digital commerce
right so what we are seeing is customers
are now
able to start not necessarily from from
the ground floor right they've already
got this capitalistic in place
they've got a system that is architected
based on best practices
they're able to bring their knowledge of
their business
their domain and really fine-tune the
system so that they're able to better
serve the needs of their business
right at the end that's what we want
customers to be able to do right
it doesn't make sense for every single
customer to you know cobble together a
system
spend a lot of energy in building out a
system they should really be focused
on how do they bring their knowledge of
their business things that they're
unique to the business and apply
that to the patents that we provide so
that they're able to see value really
really quickly
that's right well john thank you so much
for taking the time with us today
there's a blog that's coming at you with
the reference to
all these techniques and these customer
examples and like sean just explained
you know the goal here is to take best
practices we've learned from customers
and then give you the working code the
samples
the technical guidance so you can apply
this
at your own company and accelerate
your your path to value sean thank you
so much for the time again
the links are down here we want to know
what you think about these patterns and
we also want to know
if they're patterns you want us to
develop don't be shy put them in
comments
and we'll talk to you very soon
fantastic thanks bruno